need motivation watch top ten with the
liebe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was designed to help
you overcome the number one challenge
that is holding you back a lack of
belief in yourself so get ready for some
creative advice from Marc Jacobs to give
you the confidence motivation and belief
that you need
okay let's kick off with rule number one
live in the moment you know I look over
my shoulder and I always think somebody
else does it better I mean that is still
an issue and like I said it's not 24/7
it's a lot better than it used to be
when I'm you know you can start use
these spiritual sort of axioms but when
I'm in the moment and doing my thing you
know I'm safe and I'm good and
everything's fine all is perfect but
when I look over my shoulder and say oh
god they're so much better or that one
did it this but better than we did then
you know you get kind of get lost it's
like living in the past or living in the
future those aren't real it's like the
moment is now and and that's where
safety and comfort and and all that's
good stuff is so so you know if I'm not
comparing myself to somebody else I'm
not I don't need to be better than
anybody and I don't need to be worse
than anybody and I don't need somebody
to be less than me in order for me to
feel better about myself it's just like
just need to stick on my own path and
stay in the moment as best as I can rule
number two follow your instincts I was
given the job at Perry Ellis at a very
young age and I went there every day
sort of feeling like oh just do the best
I can you know and I was a little
overwhelmed at first and and kind of as
I became more comfortable there I wasn't
afraid to just sort of do what my
instincts told me was right and it sort
of culminated in that final collection
which was grunge which really I mean
even the the collection before that I
was just doing I was I had stopped
trying to please or doing what I thought
other people wanted from me because in
the beginning I was second-guessing and
thinking oh is this what the people at
Perry Ellis want is this what the
licensees want is this and then finally
I just threw my hands up in the air and
I said you know I was given this job
based on what people thought of me and I
have to trust my own instincts and and
do what I do and I did this collection
which was true to me and and I think it
really outraged some people which which
I to this
still sort of I don't know I look back
on it and I just think it was fine it
wasn't it was no big deal
rule number three collaborate I mean
what is it the the whole is the sum of
its parts you know that that's first and
foremost so I I work with the team of
people you know I don't create alone I
work with a group of people we start a
dialogue we talk about things that
evolves into fabric which becomes
patterns and shapes and then it becomes
a presentation there's stylists involved
there's press people involved there's
the people who do this if there's a lot
of people all of these guys involved
there's all these people oh there's a
lot of people involved and then it goes
further than that then there's the
magazines and the editors and the
photographers and then there's the
biggest and most important part of this
which is the audience that you're trying
to reach or hope to reach and the people
who buy your clothes or who appreciate
your clothes and buy through that
appreciation whether it's through you
know consumerism or just appreciation
that you start to change or tweak and
the landscape of this world that we live
in and and that is collaboration it's
not one person doing anything on their
own you know it's just a series of
people of people a network and what is
it satellite number four don't quit on
your passion what advice do you give to
someone who wants to be a designer I
don't give advice but I can share my
experience and which is which which is
that I think you know what's worked for
me is is is not quitting and being
passionate about what I do and and not
giving up so and when I don't believe in
myself turning to others who believe in
me rule number five find your creative
process what is your creative process
how do you start the collection and how
does it develop what happens is usually
I mean it can come from different places
we always start the season looking or
talking about I mean we all do I mean
it's a group of designers they're people
who work on handbags people who
specifically work on
Jews on textiles etc we all just sort of
bounce ideas off each other and I mean
out of those meetings a couple of things
stake and then we we sort of develop a
color palette but again nothing's ever
edged in stone and I'm a big believer in
it ain't over until it's on the runway
so you know a long dress can end up a
short dress and a red what if red was
the most important color to you at the
beginning of the season you still have
six other colors in the palette and red
may not be important in the end it may
just be a punctuation at the end or so
you know a collection is a collection of
thoughts and ideas and for us in the way
we work with the Atelier or the studio
here it's an evolutionary process it's
not like it's decided in a meeting and
then we go about executing this one
singular idea but one thing it's like a
ping-pong sort of match for something an
idea goes that way then it comes back
that way and then one thing sort of
spurns you know or Spurs another thought
and and that's the way it goes
rule number six be a sponge how do you
try to achieve that balance between
honoring what's gone before and
constantly breaking new ground I always
think of the Chanel quote they he he who
insists on his own originality has no
memory and so again you know it's I I
feel like a creative person in some some
respects as a sponge that absorbs a lot
of things there's or the and and it's
once it's put through that spin cycle of
your mind and how it comes out based on
the time that we live and where you're
at personally maybe the world and where
it's at politically or what economically
whatever whatever this whatever the the
reasons why you process it and the way
you do it does come out as a different
thing even if you try to recreate
something you just through it sort of
progress in cycle comes out in a
different way and I think sometimes one
makes a deliberate attempt to go against
something that you know but but it works
both ways I think fashion can be a
mirror and it can also be an escape you
know so there are people I think
certainly in fashion whose creativity
comes from holding up a mirror to what
they see you know
like a popular voice and but even that
becomes sort of that person's fantasy of
what they see not really what is seen
you know and then there are other people
who I think just absorb things and again
like it comes out in a different way
rule number seven care about
constructive criticism do you really
care about the creek accenting the
critics anymore and what they say yeah
yeah I'm a human being I mean I you know
I get hurt too I mean they're very few I
and I I don't mean this again in a
[ __ ] way but they're very few
journalists who I respect because I
don't think a lot of them know what
they're looking at so I don't sometimes
feel the criticism is valid I'm fine
with constructive criticism but I'm not
so good with stupidity and and again
it's one thing to say I like or I don't
like but to miss read something or miss
label something or to you know be sort
of out of sorts because it was raining
or it was too late the show and you were
hungry and so you didn't lie you know
that just all feels not valid in terms
of constructive criticism so there's so
there's certain critics that I do really
respect and when they don't like
something it hurts because I feel
they're right you know but it hurts in a
good way rule number eight do what's
necessary
there was a sweater we were looking at
the other day and I really didn't like
it and it sold very very well and so it
keeps getting shown to me as this thing
that like oh this was very commercial
and every time I see it I cringe because
I just think I don't want to do things
like that I don't feel proud of them but
then you know sometimes you have to
close one eye and just do it
rule number nine find your drive he
started saying you started that answer
with saying that you were propelled by
the fear and insecurity and Mark you
nodded by bigger ously along yeah
generally had
do you think that's quite common across
fashion do you think a lot of editors
and as I think it's quite common among
creative people maybe maybe all people I
don't know I don't know if fear drives
people or or ego or whatever or both but
um but I don't know I mean do you ever
do you ever sit there after your show
and go okay this is a I'm happy I'll
never do another one I'm say every time
I'll never do this again I'm rich I
think yeah is there something that you
hadn't created people that propels you
and for me it's it's that that
insecurity really and them yeah people
have that yeah it's it's a healthy thing
I think it's like that's sort of fear
you're putting yourself out there but
this this need and desire they I mean
that's so great that you have to do it
do it and rule number ten the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
focus completely I know what a luxury it
is to have time with you leading up to
the show because traditionally when
you're in show mode you are in
show mode is that right yes you are very
right I mean I'm kind of brain-dead
regarding everything in anything and
silly I'm just kind of focused on trying
to help be a part of getting this show
together whatever that might mean I'm
not quite sure what and if that sort of
typical for the creative process the the
sort of week leading up to the show are
intense and late nights you know in some
seasons I think there's just more energy
and lightness and then other times it's
more intense and focused and serious and
so the mood and the spirit is different
but the hours just get progressively
longer special bonus skip from mark on
how to just do more that I think you
could enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
take an action here we go question
number one what goal of yours do you
just need to focus on completely this
week number two what does your ideal
creative process look like
and number three what's your passion
that you're in
not going to quit on what's on your
bucket list anything live
what's a bucket list what's that things
you still want to do in your life that
you haven't done more just more of what
you owe more more alcohol have more sex
eat more food go to the gym more often
do more collections all right it all
works have a manicure normally this
isn't buy more art okay
see more art see more art and you're
making more art
if you want to see the top 10 I did on
Tom Ford check out their video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
I've always believed that if you create
something that people want they buy it I
think we're doing very well but I think
we can do better and all of the things